so
um
so last time
um in the last three lectures we have
talked about
um the
kind of the basics of uniform
convergence I guess so just a very quick
review so
I think we have proved that the excess
risk
this is in lecture two it's bonded by
this
this is a difference between empirical
and population
oh right thanks yeah sorry I forgot
uh yeah thanks for reminding me it's
gonna be a problem
if I forgot to do that uh yeah
well I didn't join the zoom yeah
sorry
foreign
thanks for reminding me so and
so we have shown this
all right so this is uh what we're
showing of the claim in the lecture too
so basically this is saying that you
only have to bond the difference between
the population and the empirical for all
states of Christ so the most important
thing is the second term because the
first term we have shown that
um it's close to it's something bonded
by one word scorpion so
um so the goal is to show the second
term and we have discussed uh how to do
it for finding hypothesis class and also
how to do it for infinite hypothesis
costs to get uh with a relatively Brute
Force discretization technique
and
um so and in the next few lectures I
guess we are gonna
um as I kind of like mentioned before so
we're gonna have some other techniques
to deal with the second term so that we
can have more informative bounds and
today we are gonna uh take a small in
some sense a small digression or in some
sense a small preparation for some of
the tools that we're going to use for
the next lecture so so in the next
lecture what we're going to do is that
we're gonna bounce the expectation of
this
so this is the next step sure
and and this is expectation over the
randomness of the the data right so this
quantity itself is a random variable
right so because it depends on the data
uh the tuning data you have because L
hex depends on the training data and
next time we're going to offer bond this
by some quantity which is called rather
macro complexity
um
and
um so today we're gonna do something
that is useful for uh it's a useful
preparation uh for doing this
um
um I guess so okay so I guess here is
the the plan so next lecture we're going
to do this and then the next the lecture
uh we're also going to deal with the
difference between
this and this expectation
so so that's the that's the plan for the
next lecture so and today what we're
going to do is we're going to have some
tools that
prepare us for proving quantities like
this
um and so that's the next time we don't
have to kind of have a have a small
section dealing with the tool in the
middle so so so I'm trying to kind of
kind of prepare us with the the right
tool for the next lecture
so a more concrete overview is the
following so the the goal for this
lecture is the following so suppose you
have some random variable
X1 up to accent
so they are independent
and random variables
so we're going to show two type of color
inequalities so the first type of
inequality is to show that
if you take the sum of these kind of
random variables they are
concentrated around the expectation this
is a
basically whole thing inequality is one
type of piece inequality we are going to
extend whole thing inequality to
something more uh General
um and second thing is that we're going
to show
that for certain for certain
type of function
f if you look at a general function not
necessarily just the sum of this random
variable of course you have to have some
restrictions on what the functions F
will look like but suppose you have the
right restriction that you can show that
even you have a function of X1 up to X N
is still concentrated around the
expectation of this function
and this will be particularly useful for
showing this inequality maybe let's call
this I here so because you can
um
in some sense maybe maybe just the C1
you know this corresponds to L height
Theta is close to L Theta because L High
Theta is of the form like X1 up to
uh plus X2 up to Accent right L Theta is
the expectation of L hat and the second
type of inequality will be useful for
proving what I said this equality one so
because if you care about something like
this
is roughly equals to expectation
this is our head
so then you can view this entire thing
as a function
viewed as a function of your date of
your tuning data of your ID training
data so this is a function of x 1 up to
x n
where these are the training data
so so basically the so this kind of
inequalities are called concentration
inequality the key kind of like idea is
that if you have a family of IID random
variables then
first of all if you take the sum of them
they become like gaussian and they
become concentrate conflict ocean like
and they concentrate around the mean of
the cell and uh and this the same thing
also happens if you apply certain kind
of functions on accident I will tell you
what kind of functions will have these
kind of properties
um
and
um and this kind of inequalities you
know not only useful for what we're
going to do
um next but also generally pretty useful
for
um
for machine learning like for
statistical learning theory because in
some sense if you think about you know
what happens in learning theory
in many cases basically you are trying
to deal with the difference between an
empirical discussion and a population
distribution right so this kind of
things will show up in many many
different cases and that's also one of
the reasons why I kind of like isolate
this part as a single lecture to talk
about technique
um if if it's just a or some kind of
like a tool that is only useful for one
lecture then we can just invoke that as
a Lemma but here I think it's more
useful than that so that's why I want to
kind of also show you how to prove some
of these things and also what what is
what kind of alignment I'm not going to
prove all the inequalities I'm going to
show today
um but I'm going to talk about some of
the advanced version of inequality so
that you know that they exist and then
when you need to use them you can kind
of find the right tools
so so that's the overview of the lecture
um so
I guess
um so let's start with the simple
version right when you have a song of
independent random variable and we have
discussed this before uh about the in
the in the context support inequality
I'm going to have a you know
um
kind of like a a moral kind of
comprehensive discussion about this so
let's consider you have around variable
Z which is equals to sum
of X1 up to X
right X i's are independent
and so so the a warm-up is that
what if you don't ignore what what the
structure of Z is right so obviously you
know that Z is the sum of independent
random variable what if you ignore this
structure
so what what if we ignore the structure
so you still have something that you can
show uh you can see you can still have
some inequality that can show that Z is
close to the expectation so here is the
inequality which is called Championship
inequality
uh
I think probably you've heard of this
you know in some of the probability
class so the Intercourse is saying that
if the probability that Z deviate from
the expectation of Z
by some amount t
is less than this thing
the variance of Z over T Square
so it's pretty intuitive right so if the
variance of Z is small then you have
less deviation from the expectation and
of course if T is bigger right if you
look at a bigger window then it's
there's a small probability smaller
probability outside the window
right so in some sense if you draw this
is something like suppose you have a
distribution that looks like maybe this
and the mean is here expectation of c
and what this is saying is that if you
look at the standard deviation
Z
right so suppose you and you look at
this standard deviation
and suppose you take t
to be something like uh standard
deviation of Z times one over square
root Delta you plug into this inequality
what you get is that the probability
that you will deviate
but this T is less than maybe let's just
write explicitly
and deviation of C over square root
Delta is less than
um
Delta right so this is saying that if
you multiply stand division Z by some
quantity by something like here so
suppose this is
the division c times one over square
root Delta Delta is less than one then
the probability in this tail
is less than the other
right so so we we so this is uh in some
sense the the weakest form of
concentration that you always have like
without using any structure about the
random variable Z
so however this is not very strong as
we'll see because if you think about
what happens uh with uh with gaussian
right so
um
let's see whether I missed a constant
here
yeah yeah
so if you think about
um
uh let's see
so if you think about the gaussian
distribution
suppose you know Z is gaussian so
gaussian Z
then what you know is that
um
so suppose Z is something like from
like 0 1 right or maybe it doesn't
matter whether the mean is zero let's
say it's supposed to mean it's mu
then what you know is that Z minus
expectation of Z
is less than
standard deviation
of C
times uh
square root
log one over the odd I guess maybe let's
say this is just a general gaussian
distribution
where the standard deviation is Sigma
and this
so with probability
at least
one minus Delta you have this so so
basically if you have a gaussian
distribution then what you have is that
for the same failure probability Delta
here you have a a stronger Bond it's log
1 over Delta instead of one over Delta
squared
so so in some sense what's it
um I guess I'm not showing this you know
uh I haven't proved this for you like
but you can do the calculation so in
some sense this is saying that the tail
like you can the the tail decays faster
for gaussian so basically for gaussian
you only have to multiply a little bit
um so so suppose this discussion you
only have to consider standard deviation
Z Times log one over Delta square root
then you know that the rest then you
know the rest of the the part has
probability less than Delta but if you
don't need no Excursion then you have to
be a little bit more generous in terms
of the the interval on that you draw
okay so so in some sense like uh the
um
the the goal that we're going to have is
that we're going to show that if your Z
is a sum of random variable that is more
like gaussian instead of like a general
uh the worst case z or or you have a
better Bond like this instead of like
the the bonds like this from the
championship inequality
so
um so it's so and also if you if you see
the in the the
if you look at a more kind of carefully
on the consequences of these two
inequalities right so uh maybe let's
call this number three and this number
four so if you have number three then
you can if you take
Delta to be something like inverse
polyun
then you you know that with high
probability
right so at least
one minus one over volume
Z minus expectation Z is less than
standard deviation of Z
Times Square Root log n so basically you
only lose a log Factor
um if you want to make the probability
very high right so
right so if you want to make a high
probability event then you only have to
multiply by square root login to the
standard deviation and then the rest of
the probability becomes very small
however if if you use three if you use
the number wait this is sorry this is
number four that's sorry for the
countries so if you use the number four
discussion like then you got this but if
it's uh if you use number three then you
if you take the alternative
uh if using
take the author to be inverse probably
then what happens is that with high
probability you have this statement with
high probability Z minus expectation Z
is less than
STD of Z over square root Delta which is
STD of c times poly
so there's a big difference between the
additional Factor here right so if you
compare these two Factor you have a
you have a big difference
so that's why we want the so-called kind
of the faster tail
um so of the smaller tail like in the in
the quality four instead of inequality
three
um
and a slightly alternative view which
we're going to kind of like in some
sense
uh switch between these two views you
know in many like they are equivalent
but like we're gonna switch this you
know
um uh very often so the alternative view
is that
um you can say that Z minus expectation
Z is less than
so for gaussian
what you have is that if you look at
this if you view this quantity like this
then you have this is less than
expectation minus
2T squared over
variance of C times n
so now you can compare this inequality
maybe let's call it five just
temporarily versus the chapter of
inequality one
so if you look at one then this is
the right hand side is decayed with t in
a polynomial wave right so it's one over
T square and if you look at five it
decays exponentially fast as T goes to
Infinity so that's another way to see
the differences right so the the tail
probability for gaussian distribution is
depending very fast exponentially fast
but if you use the Chip Shop inequality
you only get a polynomial fast decaying
um inequality and that's the that's
another way to see the differences
okay so we are going to look for the the
faster tail right that's what we our
goal so so the goal just to repeat so Z
this
is like a gaussian that's basically our
goal
but of course you know how do you say in
what sense it's like gaussian you know
that's uh there are multiple different
versions
um uh we're gonna formalize that what
does it mean by it's more like a
gaussian tail
so
um
to do this formulate let's start with
some definitions so
actually we're going to be fun what is
mean by
um gaussian like uh um to start with so
let's say a random variable
X
with
find and mean
this is a one-dimensional random
variable mu which is equals to
expectation X
is called sub gaussian
with
parameter
Sigma
is
the following is true let me write it
down it's it's not very intuitive when
you first look at it
right so I don't I'm not expecting that
you can see what this is really I mean
but this is a definition for something
is close to gaussian right so
um and the the this is not very
intuitive but the corollary is the
following so
um
so a Corollary
is that axis Sigma sub gaussian
if
the following happens now it implies the
following happens so x minus mu
larger than t
is less than
2 times exponential minus 2T squared
over two Sigma squared over sorry
t squared over two Sigma squared for
every t
are in 0.
so the corollary is probably intuitive
right so if x is sub gaussian if
you have this exponential indicating
tail Bond right so this right hand side
indicates
um uh very fast in K in as T goes to
Infinity it's actually not only
exponentiality is expected exponential
in t squared
um so this is a in some sense uh this is
a much more intuitive definition of sub
gaussian
um but um but the the formal definition
above
uh will be more useful uh for
um for the mathematical cleanness but
you can basically think of these two
hours as equivalent actually they are uh
somewhat equivalent
um
maybe before talking about that
um let's say
if you recall that
uh
if x is gaussian is really literally
gaussian
with
virus
Sigma Square
then this inequality maybe let's call it
six
then this means 6 is true
I didn't I didn't improve this but this
is something relatively standard so if
you have a gaussian with varying Sigma
Square uh then uh you you can you know
if you do some kind of like calculation
do some integral which is not super
trivial you have to do some calculation
but
um believe me six is two right so and so
basically Sigma sub gaussian is saying
that you have the same property as a
gaussian random variable with variance
Sigma Square and also because of this uh
Sigma Square
in the sub gaussian definition
is often called
variance proxy
so in some sense if you are Sigma sub
gaussian then the sigma is kind of like
you can think of as Sigma Square you can
think of it as a some kind of like
pseudo virus it's not exactly a virus
but it's the kind of a alternative
version of the virus which actually is
probably more important than the virus
itself
so
um
so that's the the rough intuition and
also regarding these two definitions of
this corollary six maybe let's call this
seven so six and seven are in some sense
um
equivalent definition
up to some small constant up to
uh
um some constants
Factor
so what does that mean is that if you
look at if you use six as a definition
then it means that suppose use 6 as the
definition or suppose you satisfy 6 then
you know that X is of Sigma sub gaussian
um under the definition under the formal
definition so so so in some sense if you
don't care about the constant factor in
front of the variance proxy then these
two definitions are you can in like five
in seven plus six and six also implies
seven up to a small constant loss
um so so basically the the way that I
always think about this is that I always
think about six as
as the intuitively that I think about it
um but when I really use the
what I really need to use the some
properties about sub gaussian and when I
really kind of like
or to prove something uh I typically use
seven
and
and also I didn't tell you why this uh
two equations are somehow related right
it still sounds like mysterious why they
are related and here is the reason why
they are related uh I guess what I'm
gonna do is that I'm going to show
here 6 implies seven I'm not going to
show seven
sorry my number is my number is a little
bit different from my number in the
notes that's why I'm not confuse I'm
going to show
seven in plus six
by six and plus seven you know requires
a different proof but if I show seven in
plus six you probably would kind of like
get a little intuition why they are
related quantities
so
um
so the kind of the the general intuition
is the following right so if you look at
the chapter right
so chubby chef
inequality
um
how do you prove types of inequality
so the the way that you prove caption
self inequality is something like this
so that you say the probability of the Z
is minus expectation Z is larger than t
this is equals to probability that Z
minus expectation Z square is larger
than T Square
and then you use the so-called Markov
inequality you say that this is less
than the expectation of this in this
random variable
over t-score
so so the last step is using this Markov
inequality
is it called Markov yes I think it is so
which is saying that if you look at the
probability of some random variable
maybe that's called y it's R than t
uh this is smaller than
uh the expectation
of y less than t
right because you know if you're you
have so much mass
lower than T then your expectation has
to be high that's basically the
intuition so and and you can see that
the the way to prove chapter inequality
is that you risk to the power of two you
raise to the second power
so so that means that naturally you can
also consider higher power and apply
Markov inequality again you can get some
other type of inequality so
so if you consider higher moments
then what happens is that you can you
may get something like this right so if
for example you can say I'm going to
look at
the fourth power
so the fourth power
um this is oh sorry this is still equal
to this right because you just raised
everything to the fourth power it's the
same event so this is equal to this
and then you can uh use the markup
inequality to be to get expectation Z
minus expectation of Z
to the power 4.
over t to the 4.
so now you see that you have a better
dependency on t
better uh or faster better dependency or
faster Decay Maybe
faster decay
in G right which is something we are
looking for right we we are finally
aiming for exponential dependency but
now we get something better than T
Square we get t to the 4. so
um but of course in the trade-off is
that our top right this quality on the
top
might be bigger in some sense than the
virus right this is the false power of
the deviation in some sense so in some
sense you're going to kind of you get a
trade off and you place a trade offers
so you get a better dependency on T but
you get the worst dependency in the in
the
um
uh in the in the numerator
so so and you can try to do this with
higher powers like you raised to the
power six with Power 8 so and so forth
right so actually they are you know
especially if you look at the early
works you know in this concentration of
quality people do risk to higher power
it turns out that there is a relatively
simple way to deal with all the powers
um this is um which is called moment
generating function so this becomes this
will make it you know cleaner so that
you don't have to deal with each of the
power and see which one has the best
show it off so let's talk about moment
generating functions
is
exactly this this thing that we defined
in this
definition we use in this definition of
defining sub gaussian technology so this
is the expectation of
uh exponential of the deviation of
between X and its expectations so why
this is an interesting quantity so the
reason is that if you look at if your
Taylor expanders your tax band was
inside
but this is exponential of something
right so Taylor expansion would be that
one plus Lambda
times x minus E to ex
plus Lambda Square over 2 times x minus
e x
Square
plus so and so forth right so and if you
write it more formally so this is
something like sum over
okay from 0 to n
and the coefficient natural expansion is
Lambda to the power K Over K factorial
times expectation and you switch the
expectation with the sum you get
expectation of x minus e x
the power k
so you can see that this moment
generating function is really a mixture
of different moments
right
like you have all the moments and every
moment have a different weight in front
of them in some sense this is saying
that you know what we are going to do is
that you are going to change the Lambda
so that you change the relative weight
in front of all the movements so that
you can choose in some sense the right
trade-off
um
between the the which moment you are
going to use and and uh
um so so sometimes if you choose to the
right lamp that you're going to choose
the right focus on the right moment and
get the right dependency
um so so that's the the rough intuition
and formally you know
um if you really do this you know
mathematically you actually it's even
simpler than this so what you can have
is that if you look at probability of x
minus e x
rnt
then this is so this is formally the way
you do the trade-off is the following so
you look at this and you say I'm going
to risk instead of reasoning to the
power I'm going to use exponential
so this is equivalent to e this
the the exponentiated version is larger
than expect natural Lambda t
right and then now you use Markov
inequality
for this explanation version so you get
expectation e of Lambda x minus e x
over
this is Markov inequality it's the
London
Markov
and now you use the definition of the
sub gaussian entity
so you say that
I guess I need to review what's the
definition maybe you already remember it
so the definition of subconscionality is
that
the moment generating function is
bounded by exponential of Lambda Square
that's the important thing right so
there's a Lambda Square in the exponent
it's exponential of some quadratic
function of Lambda so and let's apply
that you got e to the sigma Square
Lambda Square over two
in the numerator and divided by X along
the T so this is e to the
Sigma Square Lambda Square over 2 minus
Lambda T and now you can see that in the
exponent you have a quadratic and this
quadratic looks like
um
wait am I doing the right thing so
this is uh right so this is a quadratic
that looks like this right
right something uh maybe not there's
maybe some
this is a quadratic that looks like this
right and you can choose Lambda whatever
you want right there's a free parameter
so that's why you want to choose the
minimum Lambda that minimize this
quadratic so that you get the best Bond
so so take the
the best Lambda which means that you
want to find a lot that minimize this
quadratic that's relatively easy you can
just
um take the the smallest Lambda is the
global minimum you just do the
derivative and make the derivative to be
zero and at the best Lambda it turns out
to be T over Sigma square and you plug
that in then this is equals to e to the
minus t squared
over 2 Sigma Square
so so basically we show this is equation
seven right this is equation this is the
second this is the corollary I think
it's equation six
foreign
six
so so basically you start with the the
gaussian
so here you use the definition
to basically use the definition of the
subductionality and you get this table
bound uh for for this random variable
um
and also you can get the other side
right so here you only know that X is
not too much bigger than T than E X Plus
T you can also get
and also get
uh and the other side
less than minus t and how do you do that
um the the trivial thing would be that
you just flip
uh you define X Prime to be minus X
and then probability that X Prime minus
E X Prime is larger than t
is the same as probability x minus e x
is smaller than minus t
right just about a simple definition and
then you apply the what we have already
got on X Prime and then that implies the
uh what you have the the other side of
the bounds for for X but this is not
super important right it's just the the
two sides are basically the same for our
purpose
Okay so
I think okay so what I've done so far so
I have defined this sub gaussian random
variable and I've argued that the sub
gaussian random variable uh is basically
saying that you have you have two ways
right so one way is that the
subconscious random variable
basically means that you have a very
fast tail
or very like a fast decaying tail or the
moment some kind of moment you can think
of e to the Lambda x minus mu at the
moment
some kind of moment is boundary in all
the moments are bounded by something
um or in this form
so
so far I only talked about one random
variable right the the but the the
reason why I care about this is the
following theorem which is
um the men just in some sense so it's
saying that if you have run if you have
a all the X eyes right all the
independent random variables are sub
gaussian and some of them is also sub
goes so you can compose and that's the
the biggest benefit of this subconscious
Melody
are independent
some gaussian random variable
with
variance proxy
Sigma 1 square up to Sigma n Square
respectively
then if you look at the sum of them
is
also sub gaussian
with
variance
proxy sum of Sigma I squared F of Y
but
so so this is and as a corollary because
Z is subduction with this various
property you know that the you have the
concentration for Z
which is of this exponential form
right so you know that you have this
tail that decays exponentially cost
so so this is uh very important because
you know very useful and very important
because now if you have a sum of
independent variables you want to know
how fast the tail decays you can you can
look at whether each of them is sub goes
um I'm going to prove this uh in a
moment
uh
and the proof is actually just the two
lines which is actually very cool
[Music]
so but before approving the the
statement let me try to give you some
examples on what random variables are
subconscious right so basically this the
applicability of this theorem depends on
whether you can show each of the x i is
subconscious if you can show each of the
X I sub gaussian with very good
parameter Sigma ice then this theorem
applies and you guys are pretty good
bond for the sum of them right so so
what random variables are subconscious
right if like a single random variable
or sub gaussian so there are some
examples here
by the way whether your your random verb
with subconscious sometimes depends on
what statement you choose right so if
you choose bigger and bigger Sigma there
is at least either more chance that
there can be subconscious of course it's
not like it's not guaranteed that if you
choose Sigma TV is really really big you
can be subconscious that's not always
guaranteed but at least you know
intuitively
it's not a a binary question it's not
saying like this is my subconscious this
one is not sometimes it depends on what
parameters you choose
um so at least it's not always a binary
question for example for rather marker
complexity this also called random
marker variable rather micro variable
just means that
random variable that's it so basically
means axis uniform
from plus one minus one
right so
um so this one I claim is sub gaussian
um the reason is you know intuitive the
reason is that if you look at this
random variable if you look at the
density is something like you have a
spike at one Spike at minus one right
so basically density Decay is very fast
after you go outside first or minus one
indicates you know extremely fast it
becomes zero that's why it's a
subconscious and technically you can say
that um you can prove this
another T
is less than
two exponential minus t squared over a
big constant C 0 for
c0 to be o of one maybe let's say two
uh this is because
um if T is less than one then right hand
side
uh is less than one is equals to it's
bigger than one so that's always true
right I think I choose this so that yes
because this the right hand side is
equals to
exponential minus one over
c0 and if you take c0 to be a big
constant maybe two then this is larger
than one
so you verify this for T is less than
one and then if T is bigger than one
then the LHS is just zero
so that's why it's always also true
so
um so that's my sub run the marker a
random variable so that means that
write a marker
random variable is of one sub
coefficient
our subconscious with variance offer
with variance proxy of one
so
and similarly you can prove that
um
similarly
if
x minus E of X is pointed by m
so basically suppose you have a
random variable where e of e of X is
here
and if you look at a window of size n
plus M minus m
right so suppose your density is
literally zero outside and you have some
maybe some whatever density we want and
later is zero outside
then
once you go beyond the window and then
um the density has you know extremely
fast or it doesn't densely just become
zero so that's why this is uh
you know
of I'm subconscious
it's not you know you still need to you
know to formally proofability you still
need to kind of like construct
um I used to verify the definition of
course right but I guess it's kind of
intuitive that uh a subconscious just
because the tail vanishes completely
after you have the window
and there is a stronger claim
which also got the right constant here I
only have o of n but you can actually
get the a stronger K which got the exact
height constant
so this is saying that if a is less than
x is less than b almost really so your
random variable is almost surely bonded
between a and b
then
the you can prove this
e to the long the x minus e x
this kind of like moment generating
function is always less than e to the
Lambda Square Times you want the
quadratic in Lambda Square quadratically
Lambda in exponent and you care about
the constants because the constant is
the variance proxy and you can prove
that this constant
E A minus Square over eight
and this is saying that
X is
subgaussians
with
virus
proxy
B minus a
over 2.
and this is actually a whole more
question um it's not that tribute to
prove rate actually uh if you want to
get a right constant if you just want to
get some constant you know if I think if
you want to get instead of eight you
want to get 2 is relatively easy if
you've got eight you need to do a little
bit slightly more about it
um we will have some hint in the in the
homework as well to help you to prove it
um
all right so so these are about all so
this is all about bonded random
variables basically saying that if you
have you have a monument variable it's
going to be subcaution and
um also this works for gaussian random
variables of course right so a gaussian
random variable has to be sub-gaussian
right so as we motivate it right so if x
is from mu Sigma Square then
I guess formula you can prove the
following you can show that e to the
Lambda X
minus e x
you can compute this actually this is
equals to exactly e to the sigma Square
Lambda squared over 2.
so that's why sub gaussian
with
variance proxy
Sigma Square
okay
um I think these are the the the
boundary random variables and the and
the
and gaussian random variables are
probably the most
uh important examples of subconscious
and variables
um
and just a small
in the homework we're going to talk
about something called sub exponential
random variables
which is a weaker version of
subconscious mind variable so
um and this is precisely to deal with
the fact that some random variables are
now subconscious whatever variance
products you choose so
um just to give you a a rough Sense on
what the homework is about so
um so here when you define a sub
gaussian random variable you can in this
like in this corollary view right so
this alternative View
here you have t-square
so so you insist that the the Decay is
exponential in t-score that's a
relatively strong
uh requirement and there are random
variables that doesn't have this fast
decay so for example I think one typical
example would be
if you take the gaussian square if you
square the gaussian which becomes the
blanket on the name what's called like
chi-square distribution right so that
one doesn't have this fast decay of um
of tail right it's not t square is T
so so for these random variables you
still want to prove something about
concentration and and you can still do
do them almost the same as sub gaussian
variable with some minor technique with
some technical kind of differences and
that's what the homework uh uh one of
the homework question your homework one
is about
so
um all right okay cool so any questions
so far
okay so now let's uh prove this theorem
about this additivity of a sub gaussian
random variable so
proof
of
theorem
so our goal is to show that the sum of x
i is subconscious right this is the goal
right so we just use the definition uh
we start with the definition the
definition is that if you want it to be
to prove it to be sub goals and you need
to look at the moment generating
function
um sorry
I have some
some titles here I mean Market
okay so you look at the moment
generating function
and so here you can see the nice thing
about this which is that you can because
this is exponential it can decompose
very easily so you can write this as
exponential Lambda X1 minus E X One
right and again because it's independent
you can switch the expectations you can
factorize right each of the exercise are
independent so you can
uh switch the expectation with the
product to get uh expectation yield from
the X1 minus E X One
times expectation of e Lambda X2 minus E
X two
okay so this is using Independence
and then you just say I know that each
of the this random variable is
subconscious so I just won't use my
definition that each of the random
variable is Sigma I Square subcaution so
you bonded by e to the Lambda one longer
Square Sigma 1 square over 2 times e to
the Lambda Square Sigma 2 squared over
two
this is by
definition
and then you get this is e to the Lambda
Square over two times sum of
Sigma I squared
and and you get this that means that sum
of x i is sum of Sigma I squared
subcaution right so this is the virus
proxy
for
sum of exercise and you can see that
the kind of the benefit of using this
moment generating function right the the
the exponential is because you can
factorize the exponential easily right
so if you don't use exponential if you
for example use the the force Power or
the eighth power right you wouldn't have
such a nice simple proof
any other questions
okay so
um
so that's the first part of the lecture
right which is about
um a sum of independent running
variables
and now I'm going to talk about
um
a more complex function of independent
random variables
so
so now I'm going to talk about something
like this how does this kind of things
concentrate
[Music]
um
and you can see that
um in some sense you want to say that
this function f when f is kind of close
to a summation
in some sense right in some weak sense
then you still have very similar type of
bond that's the spirit and but what does
it mean by close to submission we'll see
so here is the the serum one of the
serum
which is actually something we're going
to use
for in our future lecture
which is called mcdermid inequality
so there is a bunch of conditions
so suppose you have a function f I guess
little f is the capital F iot form so
you have a function f
satisfy
the so-called bonded
difference
condition
but this for the body different
condition means so it's a it's saying
that for every
choice of X1 up to x n
and
x i Prime so if so I guess for every I
and every choice of X1 up to x n
uh by the way here this x is a little
excise because here I have I haven't got
any random variables yet these are just
the generic uh like numbers so uh for
every eye for every choice of x one
after X on and for every x i Prime which
is the which will be used as a
replacement for x i if you look at
these two quantities one is that you
apply F on X my reflection and the other
one is that you apply F on
X1 up up to X N but replace x i by x i
Prime so basically replace one
coordinate
by something else
and you look at you look at what kind of
changes you can make by doing this
and you assume that the maximum changes
you can make is by CI
so basically this is saying that you are
not very sensitive to this function is
not sensitive
to uh changing a single variable
a single coordinate a single input
a single coordinate of the input
and if you have this
bondage soccer bonded difference
condition then
you can uh you can say that let X1 up to
xn now that they are capital X
be independent random variable
and the we have probability
that f x 1 up to x n
is deviated from its expectation
by T
is less than this exponential
thing
minus 2T squared over
sum of CI score I from 1.
so so in other words I guess you know
equivalently you are basically saying
that
you're essentially saying that FX1 up to
Accent this is
uh sub gaussian
with
a variance proxy
something like sum of CI Square
maybe a big O right if there's some
constant that you may lose by doing it a
little bit
um
like like your virus proxy like this is
using the equivalence of the two
definitions right so
um so this is the more intuitive
definition of subconscion and and if you
change to the formal definition you will
lose a constant
of course you suggest that we let your
moment this is like a functions at a
kind of behave with the sums but just
would you say it was conditioned sort of
what it looks like a song but you can
have an excellent Planet X I differ by
doing the CI
yeah so yeah yeah that's a that's a very
good question so so um I think I before
I forgot to repeat the question now I so
from now on I should try to uh repeat
the question the question was that I
mentioned that you want to make some
conditions on F which make it similar to
the song right so and why this is
similar to the song
um yeah so so first of all I think a
small clarification I guess very similar
is the actual very weak side you'll see
that you know in some sense the
uh all of these conditions becomes you
know in some sense not very similar but
um uh I think they're only similar in a
sense that you want to make sure
that no coordinate is very
strongly influencing your final outcome
so when you have a sum right so if you
change one coordinate you wouldn't
influence your uh final outcome much and
and here is the it's the same thing so
basically I think whether it's a sum or
not it doesn't matter it's really about
whether you have certain kind of
luciousness uh property so so maybe just
a briefly also we can verify that this
condition contains the sum at least
right so that probably would be useful
so suppose you have
F X1 up to X N is equals to sum of x i
and each of the x i is bonded by
something like bi and
other one by AI
and now suppose you change one of the x
i how much you can change the final
outcome so then you can say that this
you have the bounded
difference condition
where c i is equals to bi minus a i
because that's the only that's the
biggest change you can make uh if you
change one chord
or x i right so so that's the maximum
kind of like range of like changes uh
for the stock and but you can see that
you know you can imagine many other
functions that have this property which
doesn't look like some at all
right so so so so indeed more precisely
I think the
the kind of the intuition is that you
want this function f to be
some reluctious
like uh in some ellipses or not super
sensitive to individual things yeah
that's the that's the general intuition
right so the question was why you just
don't why don't this assume that I have
a solution right so this is a very good
question and
um
the there's very short answer is that we
don't know how to prove that person
like uh like we don't know how to prove
that if f is Ellipsis then it's a uh uh
you have this result
so uh and uh a longer version is that
people have been actually trying to
um
kind of like this is very like like a
lot of researchers especially
mathematicians have worked on this area
and
and there's a question about what is the
right definition of Philip Justice like
uh I guess you you'll probably see in a
moment like I'm gonna show two more
General versions and they have slightly
different definition of voluptiousness
or like all the intuition of
philipsiousness
um and and there are somewhat
complicated it's not like as clean as
you expect just mostly because there's
some technical challenges uh in those
cases and you'll see also a case where
if x eyes are gaussian then you have a
very clean theorem you just literally as
you said you just assume f is
we'll get to there in a moment
yourself
right so so I guess your question is
that uh here you need this absolute bond
in some sense in some sense to make to
make sure you have to spawn in a
different condition right so
um it's you need some kind of some
things that kind of absolutely to be
absolutely bonded for example in some
cases you need exercise to be absolutely
abundant between a and b i right so so
and this is not very this is a little
bit different from the intuition we had
about sub gaussian right so before we're
saying that if each random variable has
a fast tail then the sum also has a fast
table but here you have you need
absolute some kind of absolute
restrictions right so this is actually
related to the the answer I had before
like uh if you look at into the all the
technical details actually it's not that
easy to deal with the a tail that can go
to infinite so so there's some technical
challenges here uh which prevent us to
uh to have something super clean uh I
would say so
um
so so for example if you know X is a
gaussian we will see that you have a
very clean theorem but if you don't know
excess are gaussian then it's uh
um it's it's kind of a technically very
complicated to deal with the the tail of
each of the exercise
and in some sense you can imagine right
so
uh maybe this is a little bit too
advanced but like for example if you
have
x i right so the tail is subconscious
suppose x i is just gaussian right so
and if F can square it right so suppose
in the function f u Square x i inside
somewhere now x i becomes x square and
the tail becomes slower as I said so
like the when you square it it becomes
Chi Square the solution the tail becomes
slower and if you take the fourth power
it becomes even slower so you have to
somehow
balance this right like it's not only
about the input it's also about what F
does right if F does something super bad
to for example Square the gaussian or
with the goes into the higher power then
the tail becomes slower and your
concentration becomes worse so that's
the kind of the challenge
foreign
okay so yeah so let me proceed with a
more General version and then I'm going
to talk about the gaussian version and
then at the end suppose I have time I'm
going to prove this here so this this
theorem is something we can prove
ourselves uh without doing a lot of
hybrid work and but the theorem I'm
going to introduce next is is some more
kind of like a
very challenging proof so this is a more
General version
so um I think this is theorem
3.18 in one of this book by
I guess if you look at the lecture notes
there is a formal
um this is one handle
yeah so uh so it's a book on probability
Theory so
so in this book they basically what
happens is that they extend the this
bonded difference
uh condition to something Milder and the
definition is so you start with some
definition this is D minus I
has defunders to be f x 1 up to x n
minus you take the if over Z
f x 1 up to x minus 1 Z
right so so basically you are saying
that if you look at X and you change one
of the one one of the coordinates and
you want to see how much you can make it
smaller
uh
right so because this quantity is always
one bigger than zero so basically are
saying that how much you can make it
smaller by changing one coordinate Z
right e instead you can just think of
efforts mean so minimum right so so the
difference between between this and
before is that before you require
so so basically before
in microdermott
you require
d i minus f x to be less than c i
for every X
but here you don't make that
uh you don't insist that no you you have
at least you have access as an argument
of this DF right so you define the
sensitivity at every point you have you
didn't assume a global sensitivity thing
you talk about the sensitivity at X
right that's a that's a quality and then
you can also Define the sensitivity on
the other side which is just soup
foreign
foreign
at every point but they are not Global
sensitivity and now you can define
global sensitivity D Plus
which is the soup
over all expands now you take soup but
before taking soup what's inside the
soup is the Sun
of this
Square
so so basically the the uh maybe let me
first write down all the definitions and
then interpret them
this is minus not minus one
so
and then maybe let me write a conclusion
so you get that probability
I have X1 up to accent
minus expectation of other than t
is less than expectation it's
exponential minus t squared over four
D minus so so you have a little bit
different Bound for upper side and lower
sides which is probably not important
for many cases uh but just for for the
sake of completeness let's write both of
them
for D Plus
right so I guess
one and up X and are independent of
course
dependent
okay so that's the so this is the
theorem so I guess the important thing
is that what is this D plus and D minus
and how does it different
from electromat right so so basically
I think the difference is that when you
do the the the CI in a mcdermate is you
take Soup
over X1 up to X N and then d i Plus
f x 1 up to accent
your first excuse right this is a CI
right which is a global sensitivity for
the ice coordinate and then the sum of
CI Square the variance proxy in the
mcdermen is if you take sum over I from
1 to n and you take soup over X Prime up
to x n
d i plus f x 1 up to X
my Square
so basically you look at the global
sensitivity for every accordingly and
then you take the sum over it and here
the difference is that this D Plus or D
minus right so they are you are first
looking you are taking the sum of their
sensitivity over all coordinates
at this point x when you first take the
sum
and then you take the soup
so so you know
it's probably it's not that easy to find
a concrete example to see the
differences of these two but I guess you
can imagine the the
the order of doing the soup and the and
the and the service it doesn't matter
right so it's possible that for example
you have a point x such that only for
one coordinate you are very sensitive
and for other Corners you are you're not
very sensitive so that then you take the
sum and then you take the maximum it is
more advantage to do that right so
um
and in some sense I think the the
mathematicians like spend a lot of time
thinking about how do you change the
order so
the the best thing you want to do is you
take the soup at the very very end right
selective like this one like but this
one actually there's a small soup
somewhere in the middle because in a
definition of drf you still have this in
so so the best thing would be that you
just Define the sensitivity for every
thing like like a gradient and then you
take soup at the very variant which is
what I'm going to show for gaussian
description
um but this is the best we can know for
General Distribution right so you look
at your sensitivity
uh at every corner then you take the sum
of all the sensitivity and then you take
Soup of x
but the sensitivity has to be fun to be
defined in this in this sense
uh
does it make some sense yeah I I you
know I I'm not expecting you to
understand all the nuances like I don't
even understand exactly all the nuances
like I need to open a book to see uh to
find the cases where there's a
difference I think they are actually
indeed quite some differences uh like
between these two inequalities but but
it's not like uh you probably wouldn't
be able to favor to see the differences
um
okay so and
now let's answer this question about you
know what happens if uh all the access
are unbounded right so what happens
if X1 up to Accents are unbonded
if these are unbonded like the ocean
random variable even you take F to be a
sum you probably wouldn't satisfy the
boundary difference condition you
wouldn't satisfy this condition here
either in its improved case because
clearly there is an if here right so e
so even f is the sum and x i sub
gaussian this one would be Infinity
right because there's no Bound for any
individual there's no absolute bonds for
any individual random variable
so uh so so that's the next question how
do we deal with the case when X1 after
action are not vomit
and there are some existing uh results
along this line so the first result is
called concurrency inequality which is
uh one of the very beautiful results
um
also for other reasons not only for the
reason for concentration inequality but
also like for other
um reasons not really into this course
so uh so this is inequality is saying
the following so if
X1 up to xn
are ID are gaussian
which means zero and one
so and you have some function f right so
and you can look at the variance of this
function
it didn't prove that this is sub
gaussian you only show the abound on the
variance which is something necessary to
have right so if you don't have a
boundary variance you probably wouldn't
be able to show it in subcaution
so the virus is less than this is
exactly as suggested before in the
question so this is less than
the gradient square and you take
expectation over the random variable X
right so this is a expectation of the
gradient of this random variable so so
this is in some sense the ideal type of
right hand side that you would hope for
so so the the concentration of this
random variable f is somehow controlled
by how sensitive how hot ellipses the
function f is
so this is the idealistic and the
basically the best kind of like thing
you you can hope for
um but the limitation here is that on
the left hand side you only control the
variance you didn't control the tail
um explicitly
right so if you want to turn the virus
to the to the tailbone you have to use
the championship you get one over T
Square ball
so and you can also deal with this like
with other kind of like a gaussian
random variable it doesn't have to be
like a uh it means zero and one that's
easy
um and
and you and it's the strongest thing
here is the following so so here is the
the stronger theorem which we can deal
with the tail
so so here you suppose
f is our ellipsis
and with respect to
Ukrainian measure
between euclidean distance sorry
distance
which is saying that f x
minus f y
is less than L times x minus y squared
for every X and Y in r
so in some sense this is saying that
basically this is saying that the
gradient of f x
is
uniformly bounded by L
right so you can see that this is
different from this one because here
you're quite agreeing for
for every point to be less than L and
above you require the average gradient
to be something small
so so here we make a stronger assumption
to say that this function is just a
global ellipses and then you can have a
stronger bone on the tail
so now let's X1 up to x n
v i d
from gaussian
and now you can have the tail
Bond
that would like to have
so this right T is less than 2
exponential minus t Square over 2 I will
score
so basically f x
is IO subconscious maybe all five oh
it's a ghost
but but the L is not expected gradient
the L is the absolute Bond on the
gradient so so you can kind of see the
the flavor of all of this concentration
inequality it really depends on you when
you take the soup when you take the
expectation you know like of a different
kind of conditions you can have
different uh theorems with different
strength
any questions
attack
then you would get like higher moments
uh I
I I don't think I know uh on the the
exact results of the top of my head I
think
um
I think the higher moment
could you get a higher moment from the
one below I guess I think if you want to
have higher moment you have to assume
something stronger
that's my hunch like for example this
one below will give you a higher moment
about
right so I'm not sure whether you can
have a higher moment bound that has
weaker conditions than this I I don't
know also I I don't know too much about
pdes so so I could I could miss I don't
know everything like this is the only
thing I know
oh
yeah but but indeed it is called it has
a lot of different applications not only
here
okay so we have
this is uh I have 15 minutes oh we have
10 minutes
so
it's a little challenging for me to give
the full proof for the McDermott
inequality in 10 minutes but I think
I'll try a little bit just uh you know
if I couldn't have the foolproof I can
give you a sketch right so uh so that's
the last thing I was planning to do
right so like uh for all of the
inequality above like this right
inequality this tail bonds for gaussian
I think they are beyond the scope of
this course like we we don't uh we're
already pretty we're already doing a lot
of things like in the technical part so
so these things probably even I do it I
would just invoke a theorem from a book
so so you don't need to to know the
proof for the McDermott air quality I
don't think you need to know the proof
but I think the proof is kind of
interesting uh to some extent so it's
probably Worth showing so let's try that
in the next 10 minutes
so
um so we care about you know bonding we
care about something like this right and
we have to bond the difference condition
and the the high level kind of like
intuition is that you want to
so this one can correlate you know f of
x by abstract and it's kind of like
something it could be a very complex
function complicated function of xma
after X right and somehow you still want
to reduce it to a sum in some sense but
but the reduction is is not that it's
not like straightforward the reductions
like this so the way you do it is the
following so you say that you define a
sequence of random variables let's
define Z zero
to be the expectation
of X1 after accent
so this is just nothing it's just a
scalar which is a constant
and and then you define C1 to be
expectation of f x 1 up to accent
conditional X1
so what does this mean this is a
function this is a function
of X1 so basically Z1 is a function of
X1 but you average out all the other
uh X I exercise
right so and you can also Define uh z i
which is you know
the expectation of X1 after x n
condition the first I random variable
so this is a function
of X1 up to x i
so give me x 1 up to accept this becomes
a scalar
um because all the other Randomness got
average down
so in some sense you can see that Z zero
doesn't have any Randomness and Z1 has a
little Randomness because it's a
function of random number of X1 so it's
a random variable and Zi has more and
more random x and z n is finally what
you care about
which is the
the fully random case
and and the important thing is that you
care about ZN minus zero right f x the F
minus the expectations
and you can decompose this into a
sequence of things right so like luckily
is telescoping some
and this is what I mean by reduction to
the sum so basically now you have a sum
of random variables and you somehow kind
of think of them as independent in some
sense there are definitely not exactly
independent
but uh but you're going to reuse the
the proof that that you use for the
summation that's what I'm going to see
so
um
and and if you think look at this right
so this is a this is a function of
X1 and this is a function of X2
of X1 and X2 so and so forth and this is
a function of
X1 up to X and
and yeah this depends on all the random
variables okay so and now let's try to
see what we know about each of this uh Z
and z i minus C minus one
right so first of all we know that for
every z i if you take expectation of CI
this is expectation of
expectation of f x 1 up to x n
right so so in the inside you have a
function of x amount of x i and then
outside you average out all the
randomness of X1 up to x i again
so this is so this is equals to
the expectation of f right by uh this is
called
a total law of expectation right
you can't you you take the expectation
of the conditional thing then you get
the expectation
so this equals to this
which is equals to uh basically the
Z zero
so uh
and then this means that the expectation
of z i minus z i minus 1
is equals to zero so each of these
random variable in this decomposition is
mean zero
unless you have
so basically the intuition is that this
will define c d i to be z i minus z i
minus one
what I'm going to do is that you're
gonna have
in some sense you you want to kind of
like bounce
the moment generating function of each
of the DI and then you say that because
your final thing is the sum of the DI
you can find the moment generally
generating function of the sum of the DI
so let's work on each of the DI
first right so
I guess I'm going to claim that uh
z i minus z i minus 1.
is
always less than
CI
where the CR is the bond difference
condition in the
uh
in the in the condition of the maximum
inequality so how do I do that I guess
uh let me see whether I can simplify
this group a little bit
um
in the sake of for the sake of time
okay I guess it doesn't Okay so let's
let's only prove it for Z1 minus zero
just uh
um in the inches of time so if you look
at Z1
C1 is expectation of X1 up to x n
Foundation X1
and
if you
so I guess
you can replace the first one by the
soup
over
all the possible choices of X Y
right so and after you do this
the this quantity is not a function of X
bar anymore so it doesn't matter whether
you condition exponent or not
so you literally just got
uh expectation soup
of the X 2 up to exit
so
let me see
and also you know that Z1 is bigger than
expectation
if for the same reason
excellent
so in some sense you have kind of some
kind of upper body lower Bound for Z1
um I guess these two quantities are not
exactly useful uh for the bonds what's
really useful is this if you look at Z1
minus zero
and this is then
so this is you know expectation
um FX1 up to x n
foreign
X Y minus
f x one expectation FX1 up to x n
so
um so you can bound this by expectation
soup using what we have done above
and minus expectation of f x one
so so here both the the
um and then you can put this inside
it's it's like a I think it's slightly
confusing when you really look at the
math but intuitively what you're saying
is that
what the difference between C1 c0 is
only one current right so and but we
know that if you change that one
coordinate you cannot make much
difference
so right so that's what we know what
like if for any X1 X2 up to X N if you
change only X1 you wouldn't make much of
a difference that's why Z1 zero
wouldn't make much of a difference
because the only thing different is X1
so but okay but maybe let me have the
formal proof like uh so on the other
hand you can also prove that the same
thing so you can prove this is larger
than if
the
so basically I'm I'm basically trying to
say that you know the difference between
C1 and c0 is up and lower bounded by the
the extremo case right where you you
pick your Z in the in the worst case and
this means that if you define this to be
A1 and you define this to be A2
then a maybe let's call this sorry let's
call this V1
and this A1 so you have an upper bound
and the lower bound on Z1 Z minus zero
and uh and you can show what's the upper
bound and lower bound so the B1 minus B
A1
right so this will be expectation soup
this is the extreme case
minus the if
right so this is exactly the CIS that we
Define right so if you change your
random variable in the you change your
inputs in the first coordinate what what
you can change right so the maximum
changes is C1 so this is less than C1
but uh condition
so basically this is saying that Z one
zero
is between
B1 and A1 and B1 minus A1 is less than
C1 so so this is saying that each of the
the random variables Z1 and zero
responded in a small interval and
similarly
we can also show that d i minus Z M as
one is bonded between
uh is by between something like b i and
a i
and bi minus a i is also less than c i
so so so recall that our final goal is D
A minus e0 which is the sum of c i minus
CM minus one
and we have both approved proved that
each of these random variable is
somewhat bounded
uh in some small interval and now we can
use the moment generating function
so what you do is you say you take
expectation of
um
Lambda
ZN minus zero
and this is expectation
e of Lambda sum of z n minus c m s one
so the first thing we have to do is to
defectorize them in some way
right so how do we factorize them we
just use the the conditional
uh
um
we we kind of like do the chain in some
sense of the chain rule so what you do
is that your first condition down
uh
X1 up to X N minus one so then you have
this expectation e
Lambda z n minus C A minus one
conditional X1 up to X N minus one
and and when condition on it you get
this and then the rest of the things
it's a function of
X and up to x minus one
right so so this is a um like what's
inside your condition maximum up to x
minus one this one only depends on
um
right so this is a function of X1 after
accent and as well and this is the
function of accent so that's why it's
inside expectation
and then
um this term
um because DM minus C minus one a
responded and and responding a strong
sense in a sense that for every possible
choice is for X so like you know that
this is a kind of absolute Bound for for
zMAX one right so we so we know that
this
is
this one
this is less than
um expected uh exponential
of Lambda Square
are Sigma a C N squared
over two is it because if you have a
boundary random variable and we know
that it's sub gaussian right so uh you
can verify this in various ways you know
one way to do it is you just uh
um actually actually this this will show
up in the homework this is the one of
the homework questions we Define right
so like if you have a bonded random
variable well it's subconscious right so
uh and you can find your moment
generation function so and and then you
can replace this term by
this absolute quantity C and square over
two and times the sum of the other terms
I think this is n minus one
and then you peel off the second term
again and again so you do this
iteratively I guess I've given it we're
already running out of time so
um
we got this so if you have this you can
or something like this I guess this is
actually eight
if you really do it carefully
so
um so so so yeah I guess I'll just
sketch this so this means that F minus
expectation of right so it's equals to
sum of z i minus CMS one
is uh sub gaussian
uh
variance proxy
squared
okay I guess so that's the end of the
proof but this proof is optional it's
just that we have more time so that's
why I show the proof
um okay any questions
[Music]
um
little barriers Oh you mean this one oh
yeah so from here to here yeah this is
just a
uh yeah it's just a cheaper step like
I guess
maybe technically what I should write is
maybe let me let me do this uh here just
so the if you want to do two steps the
first thing is you do this
uh sorry you do
you just do this you do the total
expectation you condition you you first
conditional exponent to up to accent
we do this right
so this is the law of total expectation
and then you find that this term is a
constant when you condition on X1 up to
X N minus one so that's why you can move
it outside
um
yeah there's nothing deep there
okay sounds good um Okay cool so I guess
see you next Monday